what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way and let's get
started but first guys guys do not
forget
we need 2 000 likes on this video to
really push it out so make sure you hit
that like button and also if you want to
be the ultimate alpha male if you want
women to come up to you left and right
and just tell you how awesome awesome
you are really get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today guys these
shirts are amazing One of a Kind the
best in the business
um I can't wait or my samples are coming
in this week so I'm going to show you
guys that live on the show when they get
in but they're awesome it's a black
shirt with white letters that just says
women shouldn't vote it gets right to
the point so it's at the audacity
Network dot store the link to that is in
the description and in the comments
section okay so we have a couple topics
that we're gonna go over today the first
is um you know as I've said guys we have
a generation of modern wives that do not
listen to their husbands um I really
classify these women really between the
40 and 60 year olds but you know my
generation doesn't really make it down
the aisle if we do we divorce but the
ones that are in marriages tend to still
have the modern wife mentality but with
less traditional skills so the 40 to 60
year old women could kind of cook
whatever like we can't do [__] we just
deliver it all the time
Uber Eats baby you know so anyways this
um mother this wife and mother
um had a video go viral talking about a
situation with her husband did a husband
cross the line when he left his wife at
the airport the husband explained they
had about 15 minutes until boarding
started and his wife insisted on going
to Starbucks which was on a different
terminal he told her she didn't have
time but she didn't listen he waited as
long as possible but when the gate agent
was about to close the door he decided
to get on the plane and the wife did not
make the connection yeah throw the whole
wife away first of all he was going to
visit his daughter so when the wife
decided to go to another terminal with
15 minutes to board the plane she made
him make a choice between her and his
daughter so there was a trip planned
before she overslept so they already
missed the flight so this is the second
time that they're going to try to see
his daughter so when she decided that
she was going to delay or just take her
sweet time like the plane was supposed
to wait for her then he did the right
thing and he got his butt on that plane
to go see his daughter these women
giving their opinions on talk shows I
don't usually agree with but today I
actually wholeheartedly agree look it
what what is true femininity and I
thought about how interesting it was
um we have all these like femininity
coaches coming out right we have all
these women that have these just like
femininity courses about you know
fashion makeup hair and just focusing on
yourself but true femininity is
listening to the men in your life and
focusing on the men around you uh think
about it like did our great grandmothers
did they really care about the fashion
the makeup the botox like all that no
the greatest Memories We have with women
are women that were absolutely selfless
and unfortunately the women of today we
don't really have gold standard women
anymore
and speaking of gold you know the U.S
dollar has lost 85 percent of its value
since the 70s when the dollar decoupled
from gold and the government look it's
just hell-bent on continuing this
tradition and from now until after the
election the government really can print
as much money as it wants and the last
time they did this inflation went up
nine percent and gold is the one asset
that has proven to withstand inflation
throughout time so guys this is why you
should invest in Noble gold Investments
you're going to get a 24 Karat quarter
ounce gold standard coin for free
because we don't have gold standard
wives anymore right so get get you a
gold standard investment go to
noblegoldinvestments.com that's
noblegoldinvestments.com or simply dial
1-877-646-5347 it's the only gold
company that I trust back to the back to
the wives sorry guys you know we got to
do this promo now and then uh but back
to the you know the I would argue bronze
maybe even lower standard of wives they
don't like true femininity is listening
to the men in your life obeying the men
in your life and
um
serving your husband that that's like
the core right it's it's a help me that
that is the core of femininity and it's
so funny because all of these femininity
courses they get it wrong like they
absolutely get it wrong they say make
these men jump through hoops make these
men do all this stuff for you when
really you're supposed true femininity
is serving
the guys the men I mean I'm not saying
do it to every guy but think about it
like think about the women in your life
that make you feel warm that make you
feel appreciated they're selfless and
when I think of these women they're not
typically women that really thought
about themselves that much they didn't
really care about fashion they didn't
really care about makeup hair and I'm
not saying like all of these things help
if your husband likes it that's the
whole point like I know feminine women
that
um like I know one and I've talked about
this couple before but she works in
marketing she doesn't even do any of the
quote-unquote Trad stuff but she does
what her husband says he says look it I
want you to work in my business and do
the marketing now don't ladies let's not
sell these dreams most of you are not
gonna date men that own businesses
that's like a small percentage of the
population so don't that that's an
exception is not the rule but my point
my whole point is these courses and all
these women they get it wrong and the
true um
the true nature of a wife is supposed to
be a helpmate so the comment section
weighed in on this and they agree get
rid of her so one woman in the comments
section Annie said it sounds like the
wife intended for him to not see his
daughter as this was the second flight
she messed with yeah and a lot of got
time and a lot of times women are very
conniving you know they just play these
stupid games so epic why is this a
question about the husband crossing the
line when there were at least six lines
crossed by the wife a hundred and eighty
two thousand likes on this guys The Tide
is turning people are starting to wake
up can Jen it sounds like she's trying
to sabotage the whole visit to me throw
the whole wife away and try again guys
we the comment section is getting more
and more red pill every day this is why
this content is so important because
really I mean 10 15 years ago this
comment section might have been the
entire opposite way I mean 10 15 years
ago the level of pandering on TV was
just absolutely ridiculous it's so crazy
to see these Steve Harvey types like and
what they would say on television
alfonbo why is everyone supporting him
after a marriage the wife should come
first he's wrong
and here is the simp it always starts
with these stamps right
um guys there's a natural order in the
world that goes God men women children
well what happens when women believe
that we're equal to men families fall
apart and um men that co-sign this are
evil and we need to start looking at
them as evil because they're simping and
pandering dust because they want female
attention and sex and you know honestly
as women we gotta we gotta be tired of
this [__] because they go out and let us
look like idiots because they won't tell
us the truth and I'm really tired of
these guys pandering to us when the
woman was in the wrong and that women
will never learn her lesson if everybody
tells her she's awesome and amazing all
the time
the the failure rate for marriage is
about 50 give or take and now let's take
the remaining 50 if the reputation of
marriage is bad that means over half
are unsuccessful meaning they're sexless
meaning the woman belittles the man
meaning it's really just like a happy
wife happy life type relationship or the
man's doing whatever he can to make the
woman happy
um so the men kind of look at this and
this is a 75 failure rate I would say I
would argue it's probably higher this is
the I mean because we're not going to
call it a success if it yeah I mean you
guys know the type of marriages where
the guy is just absolutely miserable for
a lifetime well let's we could agree
that's a failure right
okay so there's no other contract you
would sign with a 75 failure rate
uh just like they like take the emotion
take the Disney out of it and you know
what I realized guys I had this
realization we are in a post-marriage
world most women and men will not have
Happy Endings they will not have
families if we keep going the way we're
gone it's I I don't see women getting
off of only fans I don't I maybe see a
group that has a bit of a return to
traditionalism but I really think until
we start to recognize like female nature
for what it is
um there's never going to be any
progress because you're going to keep
seeing Christian women divorcing their
husbands like we saw in the Crowder
situation you're gonna keep seeing
religious women pat with Pastor women
become only fan like women you know not
every woman acts on her nature not every
woman will but women we just have a way
that we are and the truth of the matter
is when we get leverage in relationships
we're just not the best people and the
problem is we have a system that gives
us way too much leverage and we're very
much feelings first so it's the way that
we feel above all so if we're not
feeling it for a couple months or a
couple years we just bounce and on top
of that you have you know women are very
susceptible to Media propaganda uh
friend groups like we're very influenced
that's why you know we have phrases like
she was manipulated to do something
because on an innate level we know women
we just kind of go with the flow we go
with the crowd for whatever reason
um you know and I think we we sell this
dream a lot of times that there's like
special women that are like special or
different there's women I think that
avoid situations that maybe were raised
a bit better there's higher risk and
lower risk women but I see women from
two parent households
um get
um on only fans and porn all the time
like it happens all the time raising
good families so you know this is just
how women are and I don't see any of
this getting better or changing until
they change the laws or the structures
so now though the men have all of this
risk right the reward is lower and lower
there's things that you see so for
example the average woman it takes three
years of dating for her to get a ring it
used to take like three months now it
takes three years because the men you
know they're trying to lower the risk so
they're like okay if I wait three years
maybe uh she can't hide the crazy and I
can make sure this woman's not insane
this is a way around it
um now they're finding out then they
find out from their older friends oh no
once she gets the ring she gets crazy so
they say okay maybe we won't do the ring
we're just gonna do the kids right we're
not gonna get married we're just gonna
do the kids or they'll go to another
country and say I think the women are a
bit better here
um and you know what I say about men
where there's a will there's a way they
will find a way around damn near
anything and
um so something that has come out is an
artificial womb facility
and it'll be really interesting to see
how this changes Society if this is
going to be the future where women
provide such little value
that men will go to these artificial
womb facilities to get children
imagine that
um I I mean is this the future women
buying eggs and Men buying sperm because
we can't get together I hope it's not
but I don't see any indication that it's
not gonna be the birthright keeps
dropping promiscuity keeps rising and
there's really very little change in the
laws
um so let's play the video Let's show it
introducing Ecto life the world's first
artificial womb facility powered
entirely by renewable energy
octo life allows infertile couple to
conceive a baby and become the true
biological parents of their own
offspring
it's a perfect solution for women who
had their uterus surgically removed due
to cancer or other complications
with ectolife premature births and
C-sections will be a thing of the past
Ecto life is designed to help countries
that are suffering from severe
population decline including Japan
Bulgaria South Korea and many others
foreign
the facility features 75 highly equipped
Labs each state-of-the-art lab can
accommodate up to 400 growth pods or
artificial wombs
every pod is designed to replicate the
exact conditions that exist inside the
mother's uterus
Okay so you know this sounds insane and
you might think oh this will never
happen but honestly I think
sperm donation kind of sounded insane 50
years ago and that's what I don't all
this stuff is just adding in technology
to play God because honestly they've
given women too much Freedom so it's
interesting to see how we're going to do
things moving forward because on one
hand what they could do is they could
just start taking women's rights way you
know I say repeal the 19th baby get rid
of it
um or they could go a more egalitarian
route and make women more equal so they
have to be in the military
you know there are punishments for
falsely accusing men as one DNA tests at
Birth like it's kind of interesting
because it's either they're gonna give
us more of the responsibility or just
keep doing we're doing and it you kind
of Wonder is AI going to replace all
these jobs and then we just won't I
guess maybe need as big of a population
and this is the future I don't know
um but right now I mean they're they're
making AI sex doll type [__] and then
they're also making these artificial
wombs like at the rate we're going
ladies we have like zero to no value
it's it's bad
Jonas says interesting if this is only
used for people who are infertile I
don't have any issues with it however
research shows that the structure of the
brain changes in women after they give
birth giving them a rise in their
ability to feel empathy and respond to
the baby's needs if the baby develops in
an artificial room womb I don't know how
this impacts the instinctual
relationship between the mother and her
Offspring yeah and I don't really like
this stuff guys it starts to become
genetic engineering playing God you know
and there's a lot of
um problems that come with playing God I
mean you see what happens when we start
like making our own food that's like
process and stuff it starts messing us
all up one way that women Garner power
and attention women realize that men
have this innate instinct to just
protect women right they really like men
just and women honestly have an innate
instinct to protect women too I mean you
see the lack of sympathy that men get
um and one of these ways women do it is
let's be honest they just play the the
often times the race and the woman card
together uh protests erupt outside a
Peckham Hair Shop following a viral
video of an assault on a black woman now
let's let's look at this guys is this
going to be a reasonable woman acting in
a reasonable way and that is why there
is a protest so like this is kind of
close to home where this craziness is
happening so let's show the video
thank you
[Music]
thanks thanks
please
[Music]
babe it's not what is that for me please
what should I do well many people are
saying that you shouldn't have choked
her no I did shocking means like
it looks like I am choking her what do
you think happened it's not joking like
I at the moment my hand was like one
hand was at the back okay I was like
detaining her and there you have it guys
there you have it look
this is the thing a lot of times the
videos come out right and there's
there's a clip that goes viral and we
don't ask
what happened leading up to this clip
this this woman was trying to rob the
store and in my in my opinion I don't
know why they're saying it's a black
woman when they should just title the
article a criminal
man handled a criminal because she was
trying to commit a crime and when you I
don't really care what color you are I
don't care if you're a man or a woman if
you commit a crime there's consequences
so
um now you have them brainwashing this I
don't even want to say brainwashing all
of these whiners outside of the store
crying for a criminal and you know you
know what's unfortunate this takes away
from real victims when there are
actually crimes
um it it takes away from real victims
because all of these fake victims come
out and nobody believes them it's the
same thing with female rap accusers it
takes away from real victims of actual
rape because they just whine and they
cry and I'm just so tired of the whining
I'm so tired of these protests if you
don't if you don't like something go do
something about it and you know let's
let's you know but let's take a dive so
now we kind of went over how women abuse
their power now I want to show you
another manipulation tactic that women
do so a lot of times women will
constantly shame men for having
standards and I see this on the right
and I see this on the left now again I
don't know who any of these people are
I'd like to say I've seen this chick on
Twitter and I think she's more
conservative I don't know I don't know
but she has a tweet my final take on men
asking women what do you bring to the
table but a man doesn't ask the question
to a woman he's falling for because he
knows what he's getting
a man falls for a woman because of who
she is
her beauty and her vibrant
energy
okay
it's the way she speaks
moves
and looks at him
when they're together the feeling of Joy
when they're dining at a restaurant or
just watching a movie at home on a lazy
Sunday
how she laughs at his jokes or the cute
messages she sends him when he's not
with her in the instance of true love
what she brings to the table becomes
irrelevant because she is the table her
existence and the experience she
provides the support and the love he
desires which is what she brings to a
man's life so I wanna I wanna repeat
back what she said because I think
sometimes we don't realize how stupid we
sound until we we repeat back so let me
let me just set the scene women only
find 20 of them that are attractive so
if you're looking to marry a man
typically he's better than you so
typically these men have worked their
whole lives to become something so they
worked their way up and they make good
money they're in shape and they have
built themselves okay and these men have
spent hundreds of hours getting to the
point where they can talk to you in a
way that you find attractive right
um that they have a job that you find
attractive they bring all of these
things just to get you on a date with
them and if you're at the point where
you want to be with him he has built
himself into something unless you date
bumps but that's that's your problem
okay not mine now
you say sir you have built yourself up
to become a man I desire and in return
I'm going to offer you
Beauty
which is bleeding and literally expires
every single day I mean he's going to
marry you for a lifetime that means he
gets you until 80 which is what we live
till so I mean at least half of it
you're not going to be that hot so a
depreciating asset now I give you my
vibrant energy
like we just say words that mean nothing
what what does that mean it's the weight
so I'm going to give you
speaking
that's what men want more talking
they're like yes I cannot wait for my
wife to come home and just speak move
and look at me when they're together the
feeling of Joy when they're you know
what's so funny but notice the words the
feeling of Joy when they're dining at a
restaurant because she only thinks of
dining at a restaurant because she
doesn't ever cook
no guys you know
um just watching a movie at home on a
lazy Sunday so nowhere in this has she
offered any value props you know
um how she so now laughing at jokes
I mean whose jokes are funny after 10
years you know what I mean like we think
so short term that we just think of like
the early dating process this stuff
fades it doesn't last a lifetime and I'm
the nice one I'm gonna be honest you
guys might think I'm mean but I'm the
nice one because I'm the one telling you
how delusional that you sound you sound
absolutely crazy this is insane I would
argue not gold not silver not even
bronze whatever is below bronze level
wives but if you want to get gold
because you can't get a gold star why
you know the US dollar has lost 85
percent of its value since the 70s you
know when when the dollar decoupled from
gold a female voted in policy and now
you know the government's really just
continuing this tradition every month
when you know I I just noticed when I
get paid I can buy less and less and
less with it because
the dollar is just losing its value and
so now after the elections the
government really can just print money
as much money as they want and the last
time they did that inflation went up
nine percent this means one thing the
security of our future and our family's
future is all in your hands uh make sure
you freeze the value of your wealth that
you are holding and make sure you invest
with Noble gold Investments today gold
is the one asset that has proven to
withstand recession inflation in just
about all economic threats Noble gold
Investments is here if you want to
invest in gold you'll also get a 24
Karat quarter ounce gold standard coin
for free go to
noblegoldinvestments.com now that is
noblegoldinvestments.com or simply call
1-877-646-5347 it's the only gold
company that I trust the generation of
the simp saying that women are so
amazing some of the men that sold these
dreams we've talked about about Steve
Harvey again a guy that puts his wife on
a pedestal and just says how amazing she
is even though really does Marjorie seem
like the type to really do much for this
man that has spent his life building
himself up
um and you know there's a lot of rumors
around them right now and you know I've
said allegedly right she's cheated on
him but he's also allegedly coming out
and saying that's not true so I mean who
knows it's kind of a he said she said at
this point
um looking at their relationship Dynamic
I would say the shoe counterfeits
um but I mean only time will tell and
there's also another rumor that Marjorie
actually was a side chick to Steve in
his divorce and now we're gonna play
Steve addressing these rumors the woman
I met is a good woman she the best thing
ever happened to me she's God-fearing
she's loyal she's faithful and she's a
kind and loving person I don't care what
nobody said and y'all talking about she
was in my other marriage and ruined it
she did she was nowhere around that my
marriage I got divorced in 2005. my
marriage was over when the Kings of
Comedy was out y'all ain't know that
though did you it was over then it
wasn't worth a quarter then it took us
this long to get to the divorce that's
when the that's when the uh official
paperwork came out but in 2005 let me
help you to something I had nothing
I lost the radio show we were on in LA
on March 23rd and I lost the only TV
show I had May 10th I mean May 20 May
23rd I lost the radio show and May 10th
I lost a TV show Steve Harvey had no
money
got with Marjorie again uh New Year's
Eve met her talked to her she was with
her kids in Hawaii we got together in
2006.
we had nothing
she didn't she didn't she didn't marry
into no laugh of riches I had nothing
but don't worry about it because it
ain't working because all we are now we
are a tighter two-handed sir
thank you for doing that and you're not
gonna split us up and we're not going
nowhere and she is none of what she said
she is and she the best chick I know now
I'm defending her
okay a couple things I want I want to
point out
but all right and you see this a lot
with guys that are a bit more blue pill
now
why can we why do we know he's blue pill
I mean he's saying all the things that
you say about my wife aren't true
okay uh my question is why does she have
this reputation they don't
typically come out of nowhere and why
does her daughter have a very similar
reputation
um and he keeps attributing we built
this together now guys
men that are going to be successful are
going to be successful regardless and
men with a more bloop Hill mindset
attribute their success to their wife
because she was there
and somehow the wife convinces them a
lot of times that she was equally as
important and he wouldn't have made it
without her
oh no
tell me Bill Jeff Bezos would be Jeff
Bezos without his wife
um Elon Musk would have been Elon Musk
without his wife um garyvee
um I know he just got divorced
um would have been just the success of
just as successful without his wife
um the wise can wives can be a great
support system but this idea that the
women built the men really is just
putting the women on a pedestal we don't
deserve
um and really they should just be happy
they were there to support him
um you know he he's denying all the
rumors so you know we're just gonna wait
and see my feeling is that even if they
were true I I think his brand I mean
guys there's like millions of dollars
based on his brand I just think no
matter what he would kind of stick it
out that's my gut feeling
um and then he also I actually do
believe him after hearing this I do
believe him about the 2005 to 2006
because this is what women do let me he
lost everything and the woman left
I mean typical like let's you know what
I mean like ah okay okay
um and a lot of times what women will do
is they'll accuse the guy of cheating in
a divorce when they divorced him first
and then maybe it takes a couple years
for the paperwork to be ironed out
um usually because the woman's dragging
it out and then she'll cry to the media
and just say oh boo hoo he cheated on me
[__] you divorced them
and there's other so there's other
trends that I see okay and I see this
trend of women monetizing Beauty right
so I mean women tend to make a lot of
money in jobs that monetize Beauty so I
use Kim Kardashian as an example very
often
um but it's not the only thing let's
let's think of assistant work I mean
guys want a pretty girl at the front of
the office
um when another one I think of is sales
like there's um I can't remember the
name it's it's medical medical sales I
think it's called
um
it's all like hot 22 year olds and they
kind of know they're gonna age out
eventually and one thing that I see is
ex-strippers and sex workers uh going
into politics and this is why I openly
say that women should not be in politics
I don't really care if chicks you know
if we wanna like you know you know
there's always been political women
right there there's always been women
that have political movements and like
writers that that is like guys
Housewives have done that women have
always done that but what is abnormal in
this time period is women that run for
an office that's abnormal women should
not one be able to vote and have
political power
um and two because men have always
looked out for women's best interests
think about it guys we could be sex like
we could be sex slaves right now in
cages if all the men got together and
said this is what we're gonna do but no
men would never let other men do that
even the men that want to do that if
they do do that you know they go to jail
and Men protect us men have always
looked out for women's best interests
but women just don't we just tend to
look out for ourselves when men win
everybody wins but when we win we win
for ourselves so there was a democratic
of course Virginia House of delegates
candidate Susanna Gibson who's facing a
scandal as videos of her and her husband
engaging in sexual acts for money on
this adult streaming website chat
ChatterBait have surfaced despite the
Revelation Gibson has condemned her
political opponents accusing them of
resorting to gutter politics and framing
the release of these videos as an
illegal invasion of privacy her attorney
Daniel P Watkins is pursuing legal
action under Virginia's revenge porn law
asserting that the videos were
maliciously disseminated okay what guys
you can tell it's feminist [__] when
like what does that mean
maliciously disseminated so you know the
Dylan Dennis and Logan Paul situation I
could kind of see if you're like you
can't hack people's phones right that
you can't that's essentially like going
into someone's house and like taking
their stuff right you can't do that but
um I mean porn that they put on the
internet for free the Republican
candidate David Owen expressed sympathy
for Gibson and remained focused on his
campaign the controversy has emerged in
a highly competitive race for a seat in
the house of delegates with significant
implications for party control in the
state as both parties invest heavily in
the campaign Gibson apparently
maintained her ChatterBait profile
called hot wife experience after having
announced her campaign in July 2022
uploading at least one image of herself
on the sex streaming site a month later
she garnered
5770 ChatterBait followers whom she
repeatedly pressed for more tokens in
exchange for certain acts and private
showings she told her fans that she was
raising money for a good cause the state
Republican party and house Speaker Todd
Gilbert did not immediately respond to
the post request for comment on to use
them
that let me get this straight let me get
this straight
um decided to put images of her and her
husband having sex online
in charge of making decisions for the
country
and guys I can predict that there's
there's so many former only fans workers
strippers Etc that just run for office
because they need attention and they
just uh they they just it's really a
mockery of the American judicial system
and legal system
and political system like we need to get
these women out of office women should
not hold political power
you know I swear I've always thought
about I've thought about I should run
for office just to take away women's
rights because that's
an IC going forward but you know there's
another school of thought that's once
once we open this Pandora's Box you
can't go back and now we adapt I don't
know and now we get the artificial wombs
is that the future
it's really
I I think there's two options here you
go into modern times and just become
more modern or you take away women's
rights you know either or so you know
what do the people say about this Lou
Doug how dare he make your public videos
public yeah
I mean it's all public warrant out she's
having oh no not a Sim not a tired or a
woman she's having sex with her husband
in the video I don't see a problem so
this comment says Dylan danis uh we need
your expertise on this and speaking of
Dylan danis you know guys I I've covered
the Dylan danis Nina Agdal and Logan
Paul's story um really from start to
vanish so if you don't know already
Logan Paul is engaged to Nina Agdal
um and Dylan danis is supposed to fight
Logan Paul the the beef between Logan
and Dylan is I guess Logan's brother
um Jake
slept with Dylan's ex and he really took
this personally and they went so far as
to put her in a video to kind of taunt
them and Dylan remembered this so when
the fight was accepted and it's
mid-october Dylan decided to tweet
hundreds of pictures of Nina with other
guys now we all know some of these are
just like pictures at events fine
whatever uh but a lot of these were men
that she dated and you know
um Dylan claims he has a picture that is
very damning of Nina and it's so damning
that Nina decided to sue Dylan and is
now
um it you know and now the question is I
don't know what it is we've seen Aiden
Ross's reaction to the picture
um and apparently it's pretty bad and
now um the fight is coming up and Dylan
and Logan are confronting each other
face to face and let let's look at some
of the highlights and two of the biggest
stalls will finally come head to head in
a fight the world can't wait to see this
is Logan Paul versus Dylan danis this is
face off
Mr Mumble jumbo stumbled his way through
a sentence yeah need a happy pen in his
face
huh he said why'd you find me like this
you know what I bring you're a good
troll I'll be honest with you your
Twitter's fantastic I'm doing Dylan
you're obviously a scumbag you wanna you
wanna do half a foot you're obviously a
piece well that's a piece of [__] tell
you what tell you what
if you show up to this fight yeah
October 14th yeah I will rematch you in
MMA
[Music]
good I took the liberty of finding the
bouncer I never choked you out and I
hope he's here yeah I flew him bring him
out and I hired him as my personal
security in fact he's in this room right
now isn't it
I'll give him that it's funny I don't
mind he lives with his mom so you're
giving him a good paid days you live
with a friend on your couch yeah
all day
yeah okay I agree 20. you're in WWE
what's it called you should know how to
promote fire you don't know how to
promote you and I are at different
categories oh stop it you're okay
who's selling this fight more
[Music]
and the result is public I will do a use
out a test okay I saw you going full
send and brag about having 1500 bodies
first off okay you're a vile yeah
you can find these Gremlins how do you
find 1500 Gremlins to have sex with you
let me ask you if you do show up yeah
do you think you're gonna win of course
yeah I'd better knock you out how much I
don't care don't matter I I made a bet
to you what was it I said if I win I had
to be the best man I ever wanted okay
okay okay and if I win yeah I get your
entire purse sure and I don't want to
talk about it too much because he's all
about lawyers
I'm not shooting anyone you sent me a
season assist
I will prove it
Dylan the difference between you and I
was what I'm rectifying my situation
hell and I didn't scam anyone oh I never
made a single time
nah bro
rectifying my situation actively
what's the greatest thing you've done in
your life I'm a fourth time world
champion bro bipolar in the six years
yeah under one the best why does anyone
talk about it everybody talks about me
still when I'm having fun four years
what'd you want to fight it so why do
you want to fight together even show up
ADCC 2019 because you're so heartbroken
I have a lot of injuries bro I'm a real
fighter hard this guy doesn't know how
to train he's a train or no when you
train hard in the world you get injury
oh your back was sore nah yeah she
dumped her ass bro
you're married tell her you're marrying
this little tweet about it you're gonna
yeah
your life's going down hill ever since
you got kicked out of Marcellus
you know a little bit turn to alcohol
try to drown everything out yeah I
thought you wanted to do it yeah friends
talk about that and see what happens I
am so why'd they put the cage in the
middle so I can't get to you huh do you
hear about that yeah I did yeah because
I heard I heard that you're the one that
requested it
you're doing bad things like what you're
a bad person I'm helping you out bro I'm
bro coding you I'm trying to save you
from half of your your life work
whatever
yeah
she's a [__] Saint a lot of people do
a career a lot of people a lot of people
will be making it up though a lot of
people do make it you should be the ring
girl
you're making it up though she should be
a great ring girl yeah she was she would
never because she wants no part of you
she requested to stay as far away from
you as possible I'm making her more
famous she's ever been vile I want you
to realize how pathetic you are okay
we'll see in the rain then
you know I want you guys to let me know
in the comments who you think won that
that like face off right there
um I wonder they should do the STD and
uh dope it I think that's like dope or
whatever the the drugs that makes you
have the muscles or whatever
um they they should do that test that'd
be hilarious oh my gosh imagine I
there's no way Logan even if he lost he
would not let Dylan Davis be the best
man at the wedding there's no way but it
kind of shows back to you know uh
Logan's more blue pill mines that were
saying oh my my fiance is the same
guys she's still a woman like women have
a nature it's like we're just we're
women there's no special woman that's
not a woman especially a woman that's
like been around these high status men
for over a decade you know
um and I'm not saying it she did uh
there's a lot of evidence that seems
like she did but it's it's you know
women are still women There's No Angels
there's no Saints there's no perfect
women there's no the one it's just kind
of a Dream sold to you
um by the media
um and it's interesting too because I I
you know she's saying she wants nothing
to do with this but she's sending a
cease and desist letter to me
um that kind of says that she really is
affected by this stuff so and um
to me that that kind of says there's
something to hide I don't know
um I could see if if he if he hacked the
phone that's
you can't you can't do that but you know
um again let me know what you guys think
of the comments I'm curious who you
think won that exchange
um also guys get yourself a women
shouldn't vote shirt today Nina would
probably if women didn't vote she'd be
like engaged to a guy at 22 with seven
kids well we all got the right to vote
and it ruined everything
um so let me know what you guys think
get yourself your women shouldn't vote
t-shirt today I like the video on your
way out subscribe to the channel I'll
talk to you next time